Adrienne's with us in Dallas hi Adrian
how are you I'm doing good Dave how are
you better than I deserve what's up I am
trying to get my credit card debt and
auto debt under control uh before it
gets out of control and I would love
some guidance on the best way to start
paying this stuff off um the right way
okay how much do on your cars um about
fifty thousand for two cars break it
down twenty two thousand for one car
twenty-seven thousand for another how
much in credit card debt about five
thousand okay and what's your household
income between sixty and eighty thousand
that kind of ranges if that makes any
sense right uh your cars if we were
doing a column from smart to insane your
cars are in the insane column I know I'm
bad yeah so you need to sell both of
them okay that's what I would do even if
you had paid cash for them you have too
much invested in vehicles with your
household income being what it is your
carport okay your car poor the cars on
you I mean everything you all do has do
these stinking cars your car payments
from more than your house payment how
much is your house payment um sixteen
fifty yeah and not quite ten but your
car payments are probably of close to a
thousand bucks aren't they yeah one
thousand nine dollars yeah pretty I
almost like I've done this before
so you know they own you they own you
and you may not do this because you
sound like you're probably new to
listening to this show but I I'm a car
person I love cars and I said this
little bit earlier and I would love for
you to have cars that nice but these
cars are financially they're killing you
guys are taking your life away
and so we're I in your shoes I would at
a minimum sell one of them immediately
preferably if I could just wave a wand
and get you to understand the math of
what this is doing to you you
rid of both of them and get you to you
know seven to ten thousand dollar cars
and you know he would just you'd have
some decent cars but not stuff that is
that these are statement vehicles you're
driving yeah I could agree with that and
there's they're hurting yeah I mean they
really are and you know the question is
this here's a way to answer here's a way
to look at this lens that will help you
again because I realize and this is
shocked and I just threw cold water in
your face recall memory okay but yeah
but here's the thing where do you want
to be financially and what do you want
to own in your life when you're 75 years
old when I'm 75 and you need to be
taking steps to be able to be that
person and over that number of years and
you do not want to be the owner of two
very old fine vehicles these things do
not match up with long-term goals they
only match up with short-term goals and
um they're in there yeah they're in the
way of you winning financially so that
you can sit on the beach with your
grandkids or whatever your dream is in
your golden years your golden years are
not armed you don't want to be broke
because and go well Gail but you
remember back in the day we had some
fine cars and that's kind of where you
are right now because these things think
about if you had a thousand dollars a
month in your pocket what could you do
with an extra thousand dollars a month
you wouldnt have any credit card debt
for sure you get rid of that and you
have then you have even more room in
your budget so hold on I'm going to send
you a copy of a book called the total
money makeover it'll help explain a
little bit more than I've got time on
the radio to do
hold on Kelly I'll pick up will give you
a free copy thanks for being a new
listener
you